19 1238 nouveaux cas du coc vides ont
été détectés en russie ce vendredi
la courbe des contaminations continue sa
descente partout dans le pays
moscou épicentre de l'épidémie en russie
enregistre également une baisse avec
seulement 2799 nouveaux malades au lieu
de trois ou quatre mille les semaines
précédentes
la directrice de l'agencé sanitaire
russes rospotrebnadzor anneaux popova y
voit un présage de la victoire dans la
lutte contre la pandémie
il y as certainement un espoir que le
régime qui rend le port du masque
obligatoire soit levé cet ami et cet
espoir repose d'une part sur le fait que
nous avons déjà démontré que nous avions
appris à vivre avec ce virus et d'autre
part la vaccination est en cours pour
que nous puissions contrôler cette
maladie
au moins 60 % du nombre total d'adultes
doivent être vaccinés en russie à
l'exception de ceux qui ont déjà eu
cette maladie
aujourd'hui 20 à 25% en moyenne ont déjà
développé des anticorps contre ce virus
mais il faut vacciner tous ceux qui pour
le moment n'ont pas encore été malade pu
guérir et les bras outre la russie le
vaccin russe foot nick v est utilisé à
l'étranger l'algérie reçoit ce vendredi
sa première livraison des cinq cent
mille doses prévues du remède russe
la vaccination et débutera le 30 janvier
par les médecins et les personnes âgées
la bolivie a également reçu son premier
cargo de vingt mille doses du vaccin
russe ce vendredi c'est le deuxième pays
de l'amérique latine
après l'argentine a acheté spoutnik v
buenos aires en est à sa troisième
livraison d'une somme de 220 mille doses
les deux précédentes en ayant compté 300
milles chacune